der deutsche bundestag ist viel größer
als er eigentlich sein müsste
wir haben jetzt schon das zweitgrößte
parlament der welt nur china hat noch
mehr abgeordnete die haben aber auch 17
mal so viele einwohner und unser
bundestag wächst einfach immer weiter
theoretisch gibt es ja gar keine grenze
nach oben
419 abgeordnete im bundestag das ist
schon jetzt rekord der bund der
steuerzahler schätzt dass jeder
abgeordnete mehr etwa 750.000 euro mehr
an kosten verursacht nach der rechnung
ist der bundestag gerade mehr als 80
millionen euro teurer als er eigentlich
sein müsste
sohn mehr abgeordnete heißt auch viel
mehr verwaltung viel mehr papierkram und
einfach viel weniger platz zum arbeiten
der bundestagspräsident wolfgang
schäuble hat schon reagiert er hat büro
container bestellt als büros für die
abgeordneten damit da jeder überhaupt
seinen platz hat und noch arbeiten kann
das erstaunliche ist wirklich jeder weiß
dass jeder möchte das ändern oder sagt
dass das ändern möchte
aber jetzt gibt es eine reform die das
einfach noch schlimmer macht und der
nächste bundestag wird einfach noch
größer mein name ist bernd penthin ich
arbeite im zdf hauptstadtstudio und
dieser bundestag der einfach immer
weiter wächst der beschäftigt mich schon
seit jahren weil es wirklich ein drama
ist und dass euch das auch nervte das
habe ich in den kommentaren gelesen und
deswegen gucken uns die sache jetzt mal
an ich will euch zeigen wo das problem
eigentlich liegt wer wie so eine lösung
verhindert und zum schluss drei gründe
warum das jetzt ein desaster mit ansage
ist
[Musik]
das grundproblem ist dass unser
wahlrecht zwei dinge zusammen bringt die
eigentlich nicht so richtig
zusammenpassen auf dem wahlzettel dürfen
wir zwei kreuze machen ein kreuz für
eine partei die wir wollen und ein
schlecht für eine person und das macht
es kompliziert angenommene partei kriegt
20 prozent dann schickt sie für diese 20
prozent leute in den bundestag die sie
vorher auf einer liste ausgesucht hat
diese partei stimme liegt also fest wie
stark diese parteien im bundestag
vertreten sein wird die sorgt also für
das kräfteverhältnis im bundestag mit
dem zweiten kreuz aber wir sind eine
direkte personen die kriegen dann so
genannte direktmandate
das sind leute die im wahlkreis
angetreten sind im wahlkreis gewonnen
haben und auf jeden fall in den
bundestag kommen und die kommen auch
dann rein wenn das eigentlich nicht
durch das zweitstimmenergebnis also
durch das partei ergebnis gerechtfertigt
ist die kommen einfach oben drauf rein
dass sich dann die sogenannten
überhangmandate die tortenstücke für
diese parteien also die werden einfach
größer da hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt dass es
ungerecht für die parteien die eben
keine überhangmandate bekommen seitdem
gibt es sogenannte ausgleichsmandate das
heißt alle anderen parteien bekommen für
das überhangmandat einer partei
ausgleichsmandaten
und so wird die torte immer größer
sprich der bundestag wächst und wächst
und wächst und es gibt keine grenze nach
oben rein mathematisch können sich das
immer weiter nach oben schaukeln
wenn zum beispiel die union jetzt im
herbst schlecht abschneiden sollte aber
weiterhin viele wahlkreise holt weil die
person direkt rein gewählt werden aus
vertrauen oder aus gewohnheit dann führt
das zu vielen überhangmandaten und die
müssen dann alle wieder ausgeglichen
werden und wenn das so kommt dann könnt
ihr euch vorstellen dann platzt das
parlament aus allen nähten
[Musik]
dieses platzen aus allen nähten wird
zunehmend als problem erkannt der
vorgänger von wolfgang schäuble norbert
lammert hat das schon sehr früh
angemahnt es gibt anders noch einmal in
ruhe und gründlich auf das novellierte
wahlrecht zu schauen
lammert sagt dass die leute misstrauisch
und wütend werden wenn der bundestag
einfach immer weiter wächst und niemand
mehr so richtig weiß wie viele da jetzt
eigentlich arbeiten er hat das
angesprochen und alle haben geklatscht
und dann jahrelang einfach wieder nichts
gemacht obwohl er ja wirklich recht hat
sieben jahre später sagt er mir das
parlament muss nun auch sich von dem
peinlichen eindruck befreien dass es
wegen zu starker eigener interessen zu
einer solchen entscheidung und lösungen
nicht in der lage sein und genau da
liegt das problem es ist natürlich
schwer sich selbst zu beschränken und im
zweifel ja sogar den eigenen platz im
bundestag abzuschaffen außerdem ist es
knallharte machtpolitik gerade bei
knappen wahlergebnissen kann es ja auf
jeden einzelnen sitz ankommen konrad
adenauer wurde zum beispiel runter weise
nur mit seiner eigenen stimme
bundeskanzler und helmut kohl ist 94
auch nur deshalb bundeskanzler geblieben
weil seine partei zehn überhangmandate
hatte mit ja helmut kohl hat es wieder
geschafft zum fünften male wird er zum
kanzler der republik gewählt
denkbar knapp mit einer stimme mehrheit
hinter den kulissen gibt es also viele
die eigentlich gar kein richtiges
interesse daran haben das wahlrecht zu
ändern
im bundestag aber höre ich immer wieder
diese töne lassen sie uns einen
übergroßen bundestag verhindern lassen
sie uns das wahlrecht wieder ins lot
bringen wir sind dazu bereit nichtstun
ist arbeitsverweigerung der bundestag
muss kleiner und arbeitsfähig wert und
dazu werden wir rechtzeitig dem
bundestag auch noch mit beschäftigen und
auch zu reizungen dieser legislatur
kommt deshalb ist die reform
wichtig damit wir nach draußen zeigen
hier sind handlungsfähig ja
handlungsfähig sein ins lot bringen aber
einige bei union und spd hängen schon
sehr am alten wahlrecht und mein
eindruck ich glaube die würden das thema
auch einfach gern still sterben lassen
und die befürchtung hat auch die
opposition hat setzt auf zeit spielen
ein bisschen auf chaos und legt keinen
eigenen vorschlag vor
meine damen und herren das ist
verantwortungslos ende 2009 10 kommt
dann neuer schwung in die sache
grüne fdp und linke legen den
gemeinsamen vorschlag vor
im kern weniger wahlkreise weniger
direktmandate kleinerer bundestag die
union aber will das auf keinen fall weil
sie gewinnt wer die meisten wahlkreise
ihr argument wahlkreise seien so wichtig
für den kontakt zwischen bürgern und
politikern
da dürfe man einfach nicht sparen das
sagt mir der der sich bei der union mit
dem thema beschäftigt natürlich haben
diejenigen die noch nie in wahlkreis
gewonnen haben kein problem damit sie
auch abzuschaffen das sehen wir
traditionsgemäß und erfahrungsgemäß
etwas anders am heftigsten bremst die
csu die gewinnt bislang in bayern jeden
wahlkreis und hat natürlich überhaupt
kein interesse daran auch nur ein mandat
avec zu sparen die csu spielt wie immer
keine gute rolle bei dieser ganzen frage
denn die sagen ja einfach er soll alles
so bleiben wie es ist damit sie ihre
pfründe sichern können aber das kann ja
nicht allen ernstes jetzt ein standpunkt
sein und was ist eigentlich mit der spd
die ist lange froh dass sie sich da
nicht bewegen muss einfach weil sich cdu
und csu nicht bewegen
denn auch die spd holt viele wahlkreise
irgendwann sagte mir carsten schneider
von der spd
na ja sie hätten ja einen eigenen
vorschlag aber sie zeigen ihn einfach
nicht da die spd hat eine position wir
veröffentlichen gehört der zeitlich aber
es gestaltet sich wieder ziel war
einfach sehr sehr schwer also alles
total schwer wahlkreise einfach zu
wichtig vorschläge können nicht
veröffentlicht werden aber passt auf es
kommt einfach noch besser an einer der
schwärzesten tage in dieser ganzen
geschichte war für mich der dritte juli
2020 zu dem zeitpunkt hatten sich schon
alles so verkeilt dass jetzt linke grüne
und fdp monat showdown herbeiführen
wollten dafür haben sie den vorschlag
den sie schon ein halbes jahr lang der
schublade hatten einfach mal zur
abstimmung gestellt der druck von außen
war zu dem zeitpunkt schon so groß auch
wir medien haben darüber berichtet dass
jetzt irgendwas passieren musste und
wisst ihr was dann passiert ist
es wurde abgestimmt aber nicht über die
sache sondern über die frage
darüber abgestimmt werden darf die
antwort machen sie eine gute politik
dann hätten sie auch an den erfolg dann
brauchen sie nicht auf diesem weg an
wahlkreise herangeht will deswegen dank
danach sind grüne fdp und linke zu uns
vor die kameras gegangen zu recht sauer
wie ich finde
und haben wir so richtig dampf
abgelassen ja meine damen und herren das
was cdu csu und spd heute geboten haben
war ein trauerspiel genau so geht eine
schmierenkomödie genauso geht ein
schwarzes peter spielt und gerade die
union sollte noch mal sehr in sich gehen
ich weiß nicht mit welchem demokratie
konzept diese union überhaupt in den
nächsten wahlkampf gehen wird dass fdp
und linke sich so einig sind was erlebt
man selten der druck war also wirklich
enorm so groß dass cdu csu und spd sich
dann doch vorgenommen haben das thema
jetzt einfach mal abzuräumen nach all
den jahren sollte die sache jetzt ein
für allemal geregelt werden
im spätsommer 2020 auf einem
koalitionsgipfel weniger booms sondern
mehr rummst die saßen vielleicht so acht
neun stunden da und fünf stunden allein
hat das thema wahlrechtsreform gebraucht
so soll es fast tränen gegeben haben da
gab's sitzungsunterbrechungen da gab es
scharfe töne und am ende gab es das hier
bei der nächsten wahl werden drei
überhangmandate nicht ausgeglichen
außerdem sollen überhangmandate mit
listenplätzen verrechnet werden glaubt
es ist jetzt ein kompromiss der kann
sich sehen lassen
eigentlich kann der sich nicht so
richtig sehen lassen es gab zwar ein
paar kleine änderungen aber die kann im
detail auch keiner so richtig erklären
das ganze gesetz ist so kompliziert und
so wir aufgeschrieben dass wenn sie drei
unterschiedliche leute fragen dann legen
die ihnen das gesetz unterschiedlich aus
aber das schlimmste an diesem ganzen
kompromiss der effekt der durch erzählt
wird ist minimal man kann nicht mal
sicher gehen dass der nächste bundestag
nicht noch größer wird als der jetzige
der kompromiss der dem bundestag
eigentlich kleiner machen sollte
macht ihnen jetzt aller voraussicht nach
noch mal größer ich glaube das ist jetzt
ein kompromiss der kann sich sehen
lassen findet markus söder die
opposition allerdings klagt jetzt wieder
dagegen vom bundesverfassungsgericht
jetzt ist die geschichte da wo sie
angefangen
man muss festhalten die union hat für
sich jetzt einen mandats bonus ins
gesetz geschrieben unausgeglichenen
mandate und die mathematiker sagen uns
im wesentlichen profitiert die union
davon dass die spd so war es mit macht
da kann man sich lange fragen stellen
wie herr buschmann übrigens sagen wir
dass viele hinter vorgehaltener hand die
spd hat sich da irgendwie über den tisch
ziehen lassen
[Musik]
zum schluss die drei gründe warum das
jetzt zum fiasko mit ansage wird erstens
das neue wahlrecht löst das problem
einfach nicht dass hier sind
berechnungen auf der basis von aktuellen
umfragen und nachdem hat der nächste
bundestag 783 mitglieder das sind 74
mehr als jetzt und 185 mehr als
eigentlich sein müssten das heißt
zweitens das parlament wird mitten in
der korona krise einfach noch teurer
drittens die wichtigste währung der
politik ist gerade vertrauen und mit
einem wahlrecht dass das problem nicht
löst das keiner versteht und das
ziemlich nach eigeninteresse riecht
sieht man doch am ast auf dem man selber
sitzt und wenn ihr jetzt denkt diese
ganze geschichte ist schon empörend
genug dann gibt es da noch ein detail in
dieser neuen reform war eigentlich
vereinbart dass es eine
expertenkommission gibt die sich dann
weiter mit dem thema beschäftigt die
sollte unverzüglich eingesetzt werden
und ihr könnt euch vielleicht vorstellen
wie auf die schon getagt hat noch nie
weil sie einfach noch nicht gibt weniger
booms sondern mehr rumms was denkt ihr
ist der bundestag zu groß oder geht es
gerade noch schreibt mir gerne in die
kommentare mich interessieren eure
meinungen und eure argumente und wenn
euch das video gefallen hat lasst uns
gern ein leichter